Musique douce
...
-C'est le paradis, quoi !
-Voilà. On arrive devant l'église
Notre-Dame de l'Assomption.
On est au centre de Valloire.
On a une architecture de montagne :
aspect sobre à l'extérieur.
-Sur l'extérieur et les travaux
de confortement de l'église,
est-ce qu'il y a des choses
à faire ?
Est-ce que tout est OK ?
Est-ce qu'il y a du risque
- on le sait -
sur certains bâtis religieux ?
Des gros problèmes de drainage
et d'infiltration
font courir des risques
à la structure.
-Tout à fait.
Sur la façade principale,
c'était les derniers gros travaux
sur l'église.
Le pied de mur est piqué.
Il va y avoir
un drainage de réalisé
pour que l'eau s'infiltre.
...
-Bonjour !
Emilie Bonnivard.
Je suis députée
de la troisième circonscription
de la Savoie.
J'ai choisi de vous parler
du patrimoine religieux.
Pourquoi ? Parce que,
avec 130 parlementaires,
nous avons alerté sur le fait
que ce patrimoine était en danger.
Il s'écroule.
C'est cher de le réhabiliter,
de le restaurer.
Pourtant, c'est notre identité.
Il fait partie des joyaux
de nos territoires de montagne, ici,
et du territoire national.
C'est aussi la beauté, l'esprit,
que l'on souhaite sauvegarder.
...
Les cloches sonnent.
Musique légère
-Lovées dans les montagnes,
au coeur de la Savoie,
dans la vallée de la Maurienne,
elles se dressent là
depuis plus de 900 ans.
Des églises majestueuses
aux chapelles les plus modestes,
il y a,
dans la centaine de communes
de la circonscription
d'Emilie Bonnivard,
plus de 450 monuments religieux.
...
La députée Les Républicains
est une enfant du pays.
D'aussi loin
qu'elle s'en souvienne,
ces édifices ont toujours
fait partie du paysage,
à croire qu'ils sont éternels.
-Ils dénotent une histoire
très importante.
Evidemment, celle de la ferveur
des habitants qui vivaient
dans des conditions très difficiles
et pour lesquels la religion,
à l'époque,
les chapelles qui jouxtaient
chacun des villages
- on a de très nombreuses chapelles
et églises -
eh bien, étaient un lieu de refuge,
de prière et de pensée
dans des conditions de vie
difficiles.
Musique enjouée
-Plus que des lieux de culte,
ils sont avant tout pour la députée
un héritage commun à préserver,
mais ces chapelles et ces églises
se dégradent un peu plus
chaque jour.
La parlementaire nous emmène
un peu plus bas dans la vallée,
à une dizaine de kilomètres
de Chambéry.
...
-Tu as pris les clés de l'église ?
-Oui.
...
-L'église de Saint-Jeoire-Prieuré
est classée
monument historique.
Malgré la baisse
de la pratique religieuse,
on y célèbre encore des messes.
Construite au 12e siècle,
elle a connu
de nombreux changements
au fil du temps.
-Avant,
elle avançait jusqu'ici.
-C'est ce que tu m'avais dit.
-Elle s'est effondrée.
Du coup,
le premier transept
a été démoli,
de façon à pouvoir reculer l'église
et permettre le passage
de quelque chose
qui était un chemin rural,
qui est devenu une voirie.
On est sur un ancien passage romain.
-C'est la première fois
que je la vois.
Elle est magnifique.
-Celui qui accueille la députée
est Jean-Marc Léoutre,
le maire de Saint-Jeoire-Prieuré
depuis 41 ans.
-Et, donc, l'enjeu...
-Oui.
-...de la partie structure
et conservation,
c'est d'éviter que
le poids de la charpente
- qui commence à s'affaisser -
et la porosité de la toiture
- qui fait rentrer l'humidité,
qui permet l'affaissement
des poutres -
ne viennent télescoper
les croisées
et que ça s'affaisse,
se détériore.
-Depuis la loi de séparation
de l'Eglise et de l'Etat,
l'entretien des lieux de culte
construits avant 1905
est à la charge
des communes.
-On en a la responsabilité,
exactement comme de la mairie,
exactement comme de la crèche
quand c'est une crèche communale.
C'est la même chose.
Du coup, on est propriétaire,
donc on a les charges
du propriétaire,
de la conservation,
de l'évolution,
du respect des pratiques
à l'intérieur.
-Dans nos territoires, on a besoin,
au-delà de la question cultuelle,
de lieux qui sont beaux
et qui parlent à l'âme.
Les travaux, là,
ne vont pas se voir.
C'est terrible.
En politique,
on n'aime pas faire des choses
qui ne se voient pas.
C'est notre responsabilité
fondamentale.
-Cette responsabilité pèse lourd
dans une gestion
quotidienne déjà chargée
pour les maires,
à laquelle s'ajoute, bien souvent,
un important frein
budgétaire.
A Saint-Jeoire-Prieuré,
moins de 10 000 habitants,
la réfection de la charpente
coûtera
deux millions d'euros,
une somme que ne peut absorber
la commune seule.
-Il faut qu'on trouve, nous,
à peu près,
une capacité
de financement extérieur
de l'ordre d'un million,
pour que la commune n'emprunte
qu'un million, donc 50 %,
et qu'elle étale les remboursements
en plan de financement.
-Et on n'est que,
entre guillemets,
sur du service public
non productif.
-Aujourd'hui,
les communes peuvent bénéficier
de subventions,
à condition qu'elles sachent
à qui s'adresser
et qu'elles parviennent
à mobiliser autour du projet.
-Si je caricature,
le maire va dire :
"Ma charpente, ma couverture."
Le service spécialisé va dire,
ce qui est normal :
"Vous ne pouvez pas
faire n'importe quoi."
Il faut trouver
toutes les translations,
tous les interlocuteurs
pour accompagner,
fiabiliser la décision
et fiabiliser la chronologie
qui s'y attache.
Ca, ça prend pratiquement...
Un dossier comme ça
prend pratiquement un mandat d'élu.
-Mais d'avoir...
Que l'Etat,
avec les services des collectivités,
puisse mettre en place
des structures d'accompagnement,
des personnels qualifiés
pour accompagner les maires,
soutenir les dossiers...
En effet,
le niveau d'exigence
qui est demandé à des élus locaux,
qui n'ont absolument
aucune formation,
au départ, sur ces sujets-là,
est extrêmement élevé.
Musique légère
...
-La députée milite
pour un meilleur accompagnement
pour des maires souvent démunis
et qui n'ont pas tous
leur église classée.
Emilie Bonnivard a rendez-vous
à Chignin,
village de 800 habitants.
La chapelle Saint-Anthelme
surplombe la vallée.
-Bonjour, Michel !
-Bonjour, madame la députée !
-Tu vas bien ?
-Ma chère Emilie,
c'est gentil
de nous rendre visite.
-Cette chapelle du 19e siècle,
de style néo-byzantin,
est un bâtiment
emblématique du village.
...
-C'est notre carte postale.
J'étais enfant de choeur,
donc je venais faire
ma communion solennelle,
la retraite,
dans cette chapelle.
-Bien loin
de ses souvenirs d'enfance,
le maire découvre
une chapelle laissée à l'abandon,
en très mauvais état.
-On a repris tous les décors
pendant quasiment
huit mois.
On a refait tous les plafonds.
Tous les plâtres étaient tombés.
On a refait à l'identique
toute la décoration
extérieure.
-Année après année,
pour lui redonner son éclat,
un million d'euros aura été
déboursé.
Pour compléter les aides publiques,
le maire décide, en 2020,
de candidater
à la mission Stéphane Bern.
Son dossier est alors retenu.
Un coup de pouce bienvenu.
-Sur un budget de 300 000 euros,
la mission Stéphane Bern,
c'est 258 000 euros,
donc c'est quasiment la totalité.
-Ca demande une mobilisation
des élus
et des parlementaires.
Il faut qu'on défende
nos dossiers.
C'était un dossier
facile à défendre,
dans le sens
où il représente vraiment
le patrimoine savoyard.
Il est au milieu des vignes.
Il est dans la combe de Savoie.
Il est vu.
Si la chapelle s'était effondrée,
ça se serait vu.
Ca aurait fait du bruit,
donc je pense que ça a motivé
la mission Bern,
aussi sur le côté intérieur,
d'être associée
à ce projet de la commune.
-Reste que
ce dispositif est limité.
Cette année-là,
sur 1500 dossiers déposés,
seul celui de Chignin
a été retenu.
Musique douce
Alors, comment aller plus loin
pour aider les petites communes ?
En septembre dernier,
Emmanuel Macron annonce
une nouvelle collecte nationale,
une sorte de cagnotte solidaire
pour récolter 200 millions d'euros
en quatre ans.
...
Mais la solidarité des Français
pourra-t-elle être
la seule solution à la sauvegarde
de ce patrimoine en péril ?
Ce matin-là,
le maire de Valloire
emmène la députée
à 1500 mètres d'altitude.
-Bonjour, Bruno.
Merci beaucoup de votre accueil
et de votre investissement.
-Bruno et Brigitte habitent ici
et ont décidé d'offrir
de leur temps libre
pour préserver le patrimoine
de leur hameau.
La chapelle du Col
est l'une des 17 de Valloire.
-Avant,
ces chapelles ne rassemblaient
que les chrétiens, on va dire.
Aujourd'hui, ça va au-delà.
Elles rassemblent des gens
pas spécialement croyants,
mais qui rénovent.
Une dame m'a dit :
"Je suis pas croyante,
mais c'est ma chapelle."
On s'est retrouvés
avec une vingtaine de bénévoles.
Chacun ramène quelque chose,
si bien que, dedans,
il y a plus de bouteilles
que d'hosties.
-Allez.
-On vous fait voir ?
Je passe devant.
-Au fil des saisons,
ils retapent,
rénovent et entretiennent
la chapelle,
pour lui donner
une nouvelle jeunesse.
-On a de la chance.
Il y a un couple
qui vient en vacances
à Valloire.
Ils ont une entreprise de peinture
dans le nord
de la France.
Ils nous ont fait
un don de peinture.
Déjà, c'était colossal.
Avec les bénévoles,
on a repeint les murs.
Il y a quand même trois couches.
-Ah oui !
-Ils sont venus, le couple,
pendant leur temps de vacances
pour refaire tout ça.
-Donc c'est des bénévoles...
-C'est un don, si vous voulez.
C'est un mécénat. Voilà.
-Ce qui rassure un peu,
c'est de voir que,
ce qui est notre bien commun,
notre patrimoine commun,
eh bien,
on se l'approprie tous.
C'est pas que les élus.
C'est pas que la commune.
Les habitants mettent aussi
la main à la pâte.
Ca, ça montre l'attachement,
véritablement,
de nos concitoyens
à leur patrimoine.
-A terme,
l'objectif de l'association
serait d'y installer
des expositions photo
pour en faire profiter
locaux et touristes.
Musique douce
A Saint-Jean-de-Maurienne,
le maire a, lui,
décidé de faire renaître
son église, fermée au public
depuis deux générations.
...
-Voilà l'église Notre-Dame.
-Superbe.
...
-Durant plusieurs mois,
les artisans locaux ont travaillé
des centaines d'heures
pour rénover l'église Notre-Dame
et aboutir à ce résultat.
...
-Magnifiques lustres.
-Un maître verrier.
Il y a l'industrie,
le tourisme, le ferroviaire
et les fortifications.
Quatre thèmes se répètent
à chaque fois.
-Autrefois sacralisée,
cette église est transformée
aujourd'hui
en lieu de culture :
3,5 millions d'euros
de travaux,
avec un soutien important
de la région.
-En termes
d'équilibre économique,
je ne suis pas sûre
qu'on arrive, vous voyez,
même avec des événements privés,
à amortir l'investissement
qui a été mis.
Pour moi, c'est important
qu'on n'en fasse pas n'importe quoi.
On peut désacraliser un bien,
mais dans l'esprit,
le fait que
ce soit notre bien commun,
en termes
de patrimoine mémoriel,
c'est important.
Une boîte de nuit
dans une chapelle,
je...
Personnellement,
je ne serais pas d'accord.
Evidemment, rien n'est impossible.
Musique prenante
-Une course contre-la-montre
est tout de même lancée.
Selon un rapport du Sénat,
d'ici à six ans,
ce sont entre 3000 et 5000 églises
qui disparaîtront.
Face à ce constat,
Emilie Bonnivard,
signataire de plusieurs propositions
de résolution,
continuera à défendre
les 42 000 églises de France,
un record mondial après l'Italie.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA